hello and welcome to the lobby game
spots weekly hangar every tuesday at 2
pm pacific right here on gamespot.com
right here on twitch.tv forward slash
gamespot i'm on youtube as well we are
live we're back
no more messing about with this vod
let's patch it up later nonsense peter
brown we're live on the internet
this is live right now i can't believe
about that [ __ ] you just said i can't
believe be about the curse you're about
to say travis gafford holy moly holy
moly there you go
god damn it we get you on the show
finally and you come out with trash like
that my first line ever holy moly you're
an awful person yeah we've got a great
show today we've got aaron sampson
coming on to talk about his experience
playing the division uh chris waters is
going to come out and talk to us all
about oscar nominations what we think
should win what we think should lose
what we think was oddly admitted uh
we've got you and peter to talk about
resident evil
zero hd remaster you got it
that's a name and travis you're here to
talk about the esports it's an up and
coming thing
this is it's great you're here because
we wanted to talk about uh
espn and esports and everything and i
was i i reached out to espn and we're
gonna get them on i think maybe later in
the week i'm gonna talk to some of those
folks i reached out to rod of course who
used to work here at gamespot as well um
so we're gonna get those guys in later
in the week but you were just so happy
to be in town today so yeah i know this
was great i woke up and had a a dm from
you asking if i could skype in and i
said well why why would i do that when
i'm right around the corner i could just
come and sit down so perfect yeah so
you're just fresh back from
north american lcs right yes yeah
exactly so down in la uh for those that
that don't know i do work at gamespot uh
but sometimes a little little hidden
away because i just do the esports stuff
and i'm down in los angeles too so i not
nothing that i'm never around this the
office here to to show up in any of the
yeah once in a blue moon
uh but yeah and alcs just kicked off
this uh
this weekend and uh that's really
exciting and another big exciting thing
that's happening at least you know when
it comes to folks like us who are sort
of we're not we're not within the sort
of esports community but we're very much
like interested in what's going on is
what's happening with espn it's
interesting a couple of weeks ago bobby
kodak was saying that uh when they
bought mlg they said this is part of our
future plans to be the espn of esports
and it turns out espn wants to also beat
the espn of esports uh they've set up
this new section on their site they're
sort of they've been dabbling in in
esports before they of course had the
international uh on a while ago as well
like
from you right from somebody who's been
covering esports covering league of
legends for so long what does this say
to you that espn are getting involved i
mean it's really interesting i think for
a long time especially within the
esports community there was a lot of
desire for validation because i think
the the general sentiment among
the esports community and fans and
people working in it is that esports are
on par with traditional sports uh you
know the physical athletic sports and
you know anytime that ends up happening
or anytime that conversations uh starts
up sports fans and and even prominent
figures at espn and other places have
said
oh this is a joke you know like they
just talked about it as a nerd thing and
whatever uh so i do think that there's a
great deal of validation for seeing them
come in and i i imagine it's only a sign
of things to come as as we start to see
kind of this this interesting venn
diagram blur of of you know game sites
like game spot that cover esports and
then you know obviously sports sites
like espn covering
esports as well yeah so there's i guess
this wind change has been happening for
years but even in terms of months like i
remember there was a story in kotaku a
couple of months ago when espn aired i
think it was like a hearthstone
tournament or something espn2 was like
it was uh heroes of the dorm the heroes
oh okay here's a legion tournament yeah
yeah and one of them there's some really
great uh tweets about it i can't believe
espn2 were showing nerds playing video
games uh says a self-confessed nerd who
played plays fantasy football my
favorite one is can we all just take a
moment to appreciate that the world of
warcraft championship is on espn2 yeah
uh do you think like this is like a big
statement then this is is this more
representative of people becoming
okay with esports more or yeah is this
them looking for an in on something
that's quite profitable i mean it's a
little bit of both right like i don't
think a company is going to be
interested in covering something that no
one's really interested in but i do
think that
it also sort of shows that
people that are making those kind of
tweets
uh quite frankly
their opinion is relevant whenever it
comes to this discussion because what
what is actually happening is you're
seeing more and more i mean bbc
broadcast uh league of legends uh world
championships a couple months ago
espn is getting in like the sports
sites sports uh companies you know more
and more sponsors are coming in all of
those people are validating
esports as a sport and so it doesn't
really matter at the end of the day like
if a sports fan who is only interested
in watching mlb isn't interested in
esports or doesn't feel like it's
a sport because the everybody else is
deciding that it is all the people that
are actually covering the stuff all the
people that are making business deals
around it you know do think that so i
think and all the people who watch it
right exactly and i mean that's yeah
that's the thing is that the viewership
is there and it's only growing uh fans
are more passionate fans are getting
more interest in the stuff you know more
and more stuff esports are coming along
cs go getting bigger and bigger every
year lee continues to be a juggernaut
like it's just this is in my opinion the
future and we're only going to see this
stuff it's going to be very funny to
look back on any of this footage or any
of these comments like 20 30 40 years
down the road whenever you know there's
just it's just commonly accepted yeah
okay let me let me if you'll allow me to
digress and be self-indulgent for a
little second let me transport maybe
this a couple of years ahead further
into the future and i want to talk to
peter about this a little bit if what
we're seeing is the mass media
getting into something like esports
which for a long time was this sort of
bubble right we kind of feel the same
way about video games right when we were
growing up it was specialist magazine
specialist price there were some
mainstream television dabbling into it
but for the most part it was sort of off
temperature and it never really clicked
right we don't have a long series of
television shows that that sort of
lasted the test of time when it comes to
games
looking ahead say like something like
five years time if something like
esports which is this super sort of like
small passionate well not small sorry
but like this like very passionate
community focused community i'll say um
is is is something that espn are trying
to get into do you think maybe this is
the the start of the mainstream press
you know in the way we've seen
mainstream culture really latch onto
games in the past two years uh try and
sort of finally
grab the gaming audience like do you see
this happening outside of esports i
think it'll be easier for
excuse me for esports content to be like
easily consumable and like to discover
it but the one thing that i really
wonder about is whether espn is the
right brand for people who are already
interested in esports because they are
aligned with things like football and
baseball and so while i don't think that
espn will fail what they're attempting i
think what they're going to do is
provide a foundation that other people
will then
look use as an example to bolster up
maybe a more community focused like
esport thing that like i'm really from
the outside looking in but
you know for me like so many people who
consume esports content they're i hate
that i just said consume content
the people who get that stuff you know
don't worry we'll edit it out later yeah
they do it on twitch they do it on
youtube right like they're engaging with
this stuff the way that they have been
and i don't know if they're gonna then
flock to espn but again like you were
saying i think it's a good example of
sort of the economy of esports being
validated by these bigger players that i
think will then provide a a solid
foundation
um it's still hard to tell like you know
when the balance is going to tip in
terms of mainstream people wanting this
because i think there are even a lot of
people like our age
and
i don't know who is the outlier and you
know who's the exception to this but not
all of us like esports right but the
younger generation they really do so i
think this might actually provide a
stronger like long-term gain for things
rather than the short term so i could
see it making it more mainstream and
more popular but i think espn's gonna
have maybe a rough time it's an
interesting question isn't it because
like if there is this big sort of
clanism or in esports and there's sort
of there well needed to be because like
i remember being super into
counter-strike and sort of being vaguely
interested in watching competitive games
and when i tried to break through and it
kind of did and then it like petered out
again like the community in these like
esport games from my outside perspective
they seem to understand that if they
want this stuff to really work they need
to be passionate they need to give a
[ __ ] so
when you see something like espn getting
involved obviously like you're saying
it's a really good sort of
marker it's it's a great way of saying
okay we've been legitimized in this way
but do you think the esports community
cares about espn's coverage
like outright do they care enough that
they to watch it because presumably if
they're happy that it exists if it
crashes and burns that's obviously not a
very good you know commentary on esports
either yeah i think that uh the solution
to that
is to hire people who people care about
and who already have following and that
seems to be what they're doing right at
full disclosure these guys are my
friends but
you know people like uh theon who is a
very prolific
writer within the league of legends
community and and covers you know all
the esports side of that stuff it got
picked up by them and he's going to be
putting features up and already has
several times and they've reached out to
eve like at the moment that this was
actually kind of an interesting story
the moment espn went live uh with the
site and the announcement went out they
only had i think it was league dota and
hearthstone up on the top yes i remember
and people were you know the cs go
community kind of went crazy about it
the the
uh smash community like a lot because
all the espn announcement went up on the
boards for all these different
communities and everybody's reaction was
like yeah but they're not covering our
game or they're only going to cover
league uh and they they did a really
good job of immediately being like
actually here's a really cool write-up
on
the smash tournament that's happening
this weekend and they posted that last
last week or or and apparently they have
cs go content going up today so i think
they're doing a good job of being really
proactive in finding people that are
already creating uh content within these
communities and really helping to
spotlight them i think the other thing
and not to spin out often too too much
of a a larger discussion but go for it i
think that what's interesting to to
wonder is what are espn's long-term
plans in the esports industry right
because if is it just like oh we're just
gonna do these write-ups or are they
looking to do more stuff like they did
with the heroes of the dorm tournament
where they're gonna broadcast it on
espn2 are they looking to you know they
they we're seeing a lot of these
companies
move into streaming traditional sports
on their sites and and doing stuff like
that are they going to become a twitch
competitor whenever it comes to right uh
a lot of these tournaments so and if
that's the case and they're you know
espn starts broadcasting a league of
legends tournament or a
hearthstone tournament or whatever and
then they're also having coverage on
their site with really prolific uh folks
from from that community i keep using
prolific it's my new favorite word uh
you know then then we're gonna start to
see
i think that brand become much more
accepted and and well known within the
industry yeah i guess last question uh
it's sort of like a personal one uh that
i want to ask you uh i touched on a bit
earlier like you were at an alcs uh last
week you've been covering this stuff for
years and years and years uh we were
talking before the show you were saying
about how it used to be like you turn up
to these events and like maybe one other
youtuber and now you turn up and
sportscenter and espn and everyone's
there um
do you think this has been a long time
coming or like are you
are you shocked in 2016 did espn have
done this or does it now feel like right
yeah i think i think now's a good time i
think that the the growth has been very
significant over the past years for this
but
yeah it definitely would have been a
very strange thing for me to see at the
start of lcs you know three or so years
ago
and now with all the changes i've been
seeing you know rick fox uh former nba
lakers champion is owns a team and then
i saw the ring is that where you had the
ring on uh there was a ring i don't want
to say where i got it but yes i was the
first and probably only time i'll have
something worth four hundred thousand
dollars on my fingers four hundred
thousand dollars that was what i was
doing
uh and so yeah i like that stuff is just
happening and
especially in 2015 we saw more and more
of this uh so
it definitely it feels like
you know this is just the next step yeah
travis governor thank you so much for
coming in uh great to have you on the
lobby finally thank you it's been good
to be here and do some content with you
now i'm going to
just get up and actually
we're not doing any trailers so you just
take your cans off and walk out and
hopefully there's a there's a
short uh guy with less hair than you
standing here who's going to come in and
talk about different videos hopefully
okay i'll look for him
he's coming right in thanks so much
appreciate it see ya uh peter brown how
are you doing how was your weekend my
throat is full of crap we're gonna we're
gonna i know
it keeps coming out whenever you speak
uh i'm good i'm good my cat is ailing i
was taking care of her this weekend
watched a bunch of
anime and live action adaption of anime
live
anime adoption why do you like cats cats
hate people cats are cool my cat loves
me
because i'm warm and i feel losing you
yeah when are you gonna get that i use
her they just use you i use my yeah i
went to sleep last night and the cat had
taken off like three quarters of the bed
which is really impressive considering
it's a cat when i have a baby well you
only have a twin size match if your cat
was the size of it like a lion it would
eat you because lions will freaking eat
you but it's not but if your dog was the
size of a lion it would still love you
if your baby was as big as an elephant
it would probably throw you on the
ground and spit up food on you well it
does do one of those things hot video
game discussions
right here on the lobby iron samson hey
great to have you here we're going to
talk about the division in a little bit
okay that was good first of all i want
to ask peter brown uh about a video game
he reviewed we're back review season uh
resident evil zero hd remaster i guess
uh the latest remastering of resident
evil zero evil zero is not like the
original remake of the original resident
evil
because
resident evil the original was remade
for gamecube it was and then they
remastered that for hd resident evil
zero unless you discount the nintendo 64
prototype that was made right it was
made
for the gamecube and then remastered for
the wii
it wasn't remastered for that it wasn't
were asked for and they just ported it
and they added new controls okay that
doesn't count so it didn't look better
no looked a little bit better than that
no okay okay
so this is as far as you're concerned
this is the ultimate the only
remastering of resident evil zero
yes that's coming out this year who
knows
capcom but it'll be fun
i got a bunch of questions uh from uh
the users on gamespot.com i'm gonna ask
you about your review i've got a couple
of questions uh myself as well first of
all uh is this game it's only like 20
bucks or something i saw it on steam it
was only like 20 bucks so it's that
sounds like a price game that sounds
right you can you can buy it as a bundle
with the remake of the original remake
right for uh the remastered original
remake for 40 total
i think uh it's on windows you played on
xbox one right yes also on playstation
4. did the 360 and ps3 versions are they
coming as well i don't know uh when i
looked at the product listing last time
it did
indicate yes but i don't have those
games in hand you haven't played them no
worries um i want to talk about wesker
mode before because no one asked about
western mode west come out to me is the
funniest like it's literally nothing to
do probably with the game but i just
love dumb bonus modes for video games
yeah so you can play this entire game as
albert wesker but it doesn't change his
voice acting or anything no so it just
replaces the character model of uh billy
yeah billy everyone's favorite resident
evil character billy yeah the tank tops
slick haired um so yeah replaces him
with wesker and billy's lines are just
stupid to begin with yeah i only see him
like utter lines that are really silly
and own it because in context it's
really weird to have wesker having
someone else's voice come out of his
mouth yeah
but more importantly
so he's like super powered um he can use
guns he doesn't have unlimited health
but he can
he has the ability to un you know
without limits release these bursts of
energy that decapitate zombies right and
you can like hold the button down and
charge it up so you decapitate zombies
that are that far away from you okay
yeah he can also run really really fast
right knock over here he is look bam
head explodes great yeah so this is he's
running super fast that looks like like
a broken animation i know and that's
just it it's like so much of this mode
is
is unbalanced right um and that's fun is
it for speed running that or something
or it's for speed running i also think
it's kind of cathartic because i um i
sat down and played resident evil zero
from start to finish uh the the day
before writing this review
um and at the end of that i was very
exhausted because that was like 10 to
like 12 hours of
you know tense survival like all this
stuff
and then it starts me off again i'm like
okay i have to try wesker mode but then
i'm just like
tearing through zombies like nothing
it's great and all of a sudden i feel
like the game is new again all this
stress is gone it's just about fun
and i really like it that's good good
bonus mode i like it so i wanted to give
some sort of a card you know a bit of
time to that because i i like dumb bonus
modes i miss cheat because i miss things
so let's talk about resident evil then
how do you when you're before i get to
the sort of user questions how do you
review a game like this because do you
review it based on the fact like this
technical exercise of oh this is a
remaster of an old game so how good does
this recapture what that old game was uh
or do you have to review it as a game
that came out you know whatever over 10
years ago and how does it play in 2016
like how do you balance that sort of
aspect well it's an old game and
therefore you have to acknowledge the
things that are a product of the time
but you know you could say oh people can
just read the old review and then we can
just write something about the technical
improvements right but
a person today their tastes are probably
very different from someone who's
reviewing the game back then like
context is everything in these cases or
somebody who's playing it somebody's
playing imagine a teenager playing this
yeah you know they weren't maybe even a
kid who's like 12 right who was not
alive when the game came out
you know in that sense you have to
review the game for what it is and you
can't really make apologies for things
that are old i think it's fair to point
out why things are the way they are yeah
but i'm getting a lot of comments people
saying like doesn't he understand when
this game came out like blah blah it's
like yes i played it when it came out i
understand that but i'm playing it today
as someone in 2016.
and some things are not that great and
uh those need to be taken into account
and
no apologies right yeah uh seven out of
ten on gay spot seven and 10. it's a
good game excellent uh b gary one asks
seeing as the pc version has 60 frames
per second option and the ps4 and xbox
one doesn't are you disappointed do you
think it would have been does it benefit
from it at all i don't think it matters
to me it didn't matter to me i mean
unless i'm playing like
an arcade shmup or
heaven forbid i ever get into league of
legends or i'm playing street fighter
right yeah 60 frames per second isn't
necessarily that important especially to
a game like resident evil i was about to
say it's quite cinematic so yeah so even
the lower frame rate like lends itself
to a more cinematic presentation and you
know on consoles they lock it to 30
probably because they wanted to use the
extra headroom for better lighting and
shadows right and on pc they probably
unlocked it for 60 because pc gamers
just want to
be able to do that yeah you know they
want to see the number and feel great
about it dude themselves yeah that's
true that's something we come across
with making video stuff a lot as well is
that like 60 frames a second is
something like for game play like i feel
like that's something they they like to
do a lot but for instance like andy are
you is this 30 or 23 you're on
you don't know you're not shooting in 60
frames like so like this one here is
probably on 30 right so like if we go to
andy single whenever we do this for the
point it's always like super low yeah i
don't know am i wrong that kind of looks
like it's about 24 is it
it might be being upscale we don't know
if it's been converted
for a while and it made it look like
they were little
live mannequins inside of youtube it was
kind of creepy like i like six frames a
second for like 95 percent of games but
yeah there are some situations in which
it just it actually kind of takes away
from the experience it's like weird
uncanny valley for some reason yeah when
we try doing that on youtube yeah not a
fun i think we focus too much on whether
a game is 1080p 60 and not right behind
maybe why
it is or is not it's kind of shorthand
for does this game look and play fluidly
or at least i feel like that's what it
was meant to be but now it's just turned
into this abstract silly well yeah cause
there's so many discussions like the
xbox one can't do 1080p 60. is it right
well no it could if the developers like
tone down some of the special effects in
the game
it's not like
everything is built on top of can the
system do a certain frame rate
resolution that's that's the result of
everything they've decided to put into
the game
and uh
i think people should actually the
discussion should be
i want this game at 60 so they should
have toned down the textures or they
should have done this right right rather
than just being like i want an all
blankly the end result isn't what i
wanted to be regardless of why all right
well to that end i'll probably talk too
much about resolution and frames right
so let's get to some more gameplay
questions spike speaker asked a question
that made me laugh out loud because this
is kind of how i feel about it did the
remaster make this game any less boring
asking for a friend
uh
uh wesker mode made it less boring okay
i will say that all right it's does it
does it feel like when you played
resident evil 0 the first time it does
yeah i mean especially because when you
know nostalgia makes everything seem
better right so
i'm not coming at this like wow this
looks so much better like it looks
really good it looked really good to me
back when it came out
so
less boring maybe only if you beat it
and unlock that extra mode okay oh you
have to unlock it do you oh yeah you do
do you have to do anything specific to
one like i just played the game i played
it on normal difficulty i saved whatever
i wanted to i died a couple times so
yeah no restrictions uh i got a question
here from savage road and i think this
might have been twitter i might have
been gamespot comments i forgot uh
everyone says item management is a bad
thing in a survival horror game i don't
understand that that's the part of
survival in survival horror um how does
that sort of affect resident evil zero
is there much of that like balancing the
amount of stuff that you can carry in
caribbeans all that that's the whole
challenge is is keeping track of enough
items to like defend and heal yourself
uh while also leaving room for key items
you need to solve puzzles and weapons
because it's all sort of in one big
pool
but uh this game makes it easier because
in other resident evil games you had to
go to designated storage chests so if
you forgot something i was like
[ __ ] i need to go slog all the way back
there now you can leave items in any
room uh and the map system is really
good about telling you where you left
something and what it is
um
and you can exchange items between
characters
that said it is a little silly sometimes
because you'll pick up
things that maybe don't go in your
inventory it's sort of like a lore item
and there's no limit to how much lore
you can carry
uh there's a limit of amount of lore i
can read right you know but it's like
it's weird when like a key takes up the
same amount of space as some something
even like a handgun or like
a bunch of like
grenade munitions yeah it's like it's a
bit imbalanced so it seems silly but the
conceit fits what the game is trying to
be and it is this puzzle of
you know having things you need to
survive and then also being able to
progress through the game yeah
interesting i i spend all weekend
playing the long dark which is basically
a game it's
only about that about having like
infantry management and weight
consumption so i think you know
depending on the game i guess it it it
either works or it doesn't um that's
kind of all the questions of what
happened to people of the folks on
gamestop.com and then reaching out over
twitter uh so i guess your final
thoughts on a peter this is a it's a
solid remake of a of a decent resident
evil game it sounds like yeah like if
you want like old school survival horror
and you
don't mind playing a game that's like
got fixed cameras
uh go for it it's not as good as the
first one but it's still all right
awesome there you go thanks very much
peter appreciate you coming on talking
to us about it and let us know what you
think of resident evil uh hd resident
evil zero hd remaster um in the comments
below let us know are you interested in
picking it up would you pick it up if it
was a full price game actually i'm
interested to hear that um do you think
you'll get it because it's around the 20
bucks limits let us know in the comments
below and in the chat as well all the
chats here thanks everyone for tuning in
at the moment on gamespot.com on
twitch.tv forward slash gamespot and to
our folks watching on youtube gaming as
well super appreciate it uh we're going
to get into the division in a second i
want people to sort of uh in the chat to
warm up and and come up with any ideas
or questions um they have uh for the
division uh but while we're sort of
waiting for that put that [ __ ] right
there uh watch you guys been playing
over the weekend you you get into
anything over the the wet weekend here
in the east bay it was or in the bay
area there was trees falling down in my
local neighborhood it was a real weekend
for like staying in and i'm playing
games yeah good for games not leaving at
all yeah did you guys find it yeah i've
been pretty hopelessly addicted to
rainbow six siege oh really still yeah
it's a game you know i'll admit it's a
game with technical flaws but it's also
one of the best examples of just
what i used to love about battlefield
which is just
there's
you can learn something every single
time you play that game right and
there's always somebody doing a new
strategy you never thought of you're
thinking of new strategies
everything's super dynamic with the wall
destruction also it's it uses maps in a
way that i haven't seen in a long time
where there's a limited number of maps
but the locations on the maps are also
different really
that
you can fight in two different locations
on the same map and just have completely
different experiences
so
is it changing as well like with the
with the player base sort of like
presumably now they're really good in
comparison what they were months ago has
that sort of affected the enjoyment as
well it's funny because i think you'll
see certain strategies emerge like one
week and then people find a counter to
that strategy for example there's two
maps it's not the proper name i call it
the waco map because it's like a map
from waco texas yeah but like it's one
it's one of the only maps out in the
ship map where you can actually as a
defender run to the other side of the
map break out a window and shoot
attackers off the building as they climb
up it wow cool and there's only two maps
you can do that on so i think people
have gotten pretty savvy to defenders
not playing the objective and just
running off on the map to random towers
and places so that was that was over
break i saw a lot of people
playing out outside of their roles
excellent which is exciting because
you really gotta
think before you go into the into each
compound thinking man shooter yeah
thinking person shooter battlefield
doesn't scratch that itch anymore it it
did for a long time it was too much of
the same it's not that it couldn't again
but i think that they need to just
completely
rethink battlefield to a certain extent
it up through three was fantastic and
then i think four just regurgitated
three
so you know you're just at that point
where you know that feeling like you've
eaten too much candy yeah it's just that
like i still like candy but i just
cannot take another bite of this yeah
and i just need i need a new flavor
awesome well i'm glad we have you here
to talk about a different flavor then as
it happens
after two years of delays we're mere
weeks away from the launch of the
division uh ahead of its beta i guess
which is next week is that right yeah
there's a beta supposedly starts on the
28th okay so i guess ahead of that
between more people getting their hands
on us i kind of really want to know like
get right down to and sort of talk about
exactly what this game is because it
feels like what the game we filled in
the blanks of what we saw
as far back as e3 2013 as to what this
game was like i remember watching that
initial trailer and thinking oh this is
very sort of like slow and intentional
co-op experience like something like a
co-op ghost recon advanced warfighter or
something like that got a massive fan of
all rainbow six games ghost recon stuff
like that kind of felt like that like
everyone's talking and on point and and
the numbers were popping up but it felt
like sort of like a tactical shooter
that was co-op um from what we've heard
over the past week it looks like it's
more like a sort of an online party
shooter where you're you're fighting
waves upon waves of of people aaron you
played it last week scott butterworth
has a great preview up on the site which
uh folks can go check out if they want
to as well uh but i want to talk to you
about what this game is what does it
somebody who plays shooters primarily
somebody loves games like like
battlefield and loves games like rainbow
six siege what is the division to you
when you when you were literally like
shooting people and playing it so the
division it's a co-op shooter it's more
so a co-op shooter than destiny is i
think a lot of people compare this game
to destiny in destiny there's people
wandering around the world when you're
playing i don't know i would call it a
minimo it's like just a mini mmo like
other human players yeah yeah yeah yeah
i like minnie mouse we usually use that
but like
mini mo problems mini mo money no okay
so the division is not like that it
really is a co-op shooter you will only
see other players in the first area that
you spawn and then maybe in a couple
other select spaces so you do have to
pull your friends in with you before you
go out into the city okay um
they're they're marketing it as an rpg
right now yeah very heavily it seems
like actually it's almost like they've
they've realized people don't think it's
not an rpg and they're sort of
well i guess whatever we or we'll get
into what rpg means for a game like the
division but sorry go on yeah so it took
destiny i think it took destiny it took
bungie a good year to realize that it
was they thought they had a shooter what
they really had was a shooter rpg so for
the division they're coming at it from
the other side they're saying we have an
rpg and the shooting is kind of a
byproduct of that and i'm not sure which
came first whether like the sort of
mediocre i don't know if it's mediocre
it's just okay shooting it's right the
shooting doesn't feel fantastic it gets
the job done
um
and it complements the world which i
think is very well flushed out you have
a very good sense of time and place in
the division it feels like the pandemic
happened all the weak people died off
and like you're right at that liberals
yeah
people can run fast enough all died it
feels like you're at that moment right
where people are like running out of
their supplies right and they're getting
desperate in these three factions the
rikers looters and cleaners are all kind
of
at their height of power
that's when you come into it now what
you're actually doing in the world
i think it's going to depend on whether
you like rpg or shooters more right the
shooting itself and the cover system is
very i found it to be very imprecise
um i love another ubisoft game ghost
recon phantoms which is another cover
based shooter and that you run you can
knee slide you can prone slide you can
get in cover and you can have three
different standing kneeling or prone you
have none of that control in this game
okay all you really have are a gears of
war dive roll a gears of war roadie run
to cover and then
the the game itself handles how your
character behaves in cover right
and it's quite interesting to say that
because when i think about what made
you know destiny such a great game to
play regardless of its the the you know
litany of problems that had at launch
and then a lot of which were fixed last
year
eventually was that it's a it's a bungee
shooter like they just do shooting real
good so to hear you say that like
shooting and movement doesn't feel
particularly great is a little bit
really but on the other hand this has
much deeper rpg mechanics which is kind
of what they're advertising so you have
three sets you have like three skill
trees that are going at all times you
have your abilities which you have three
of them
and you have no limitations you can pick
from any skill tree then you have
basically the equivalent of active
skills and you have passive skills so
you're gonna find a lot of people doing
stats tweaking um you can craft items
you can
um
you build very specific characters but
you're not you're not locked into them
like if something doesn't work you just
back out and go another direction are
you leveling up that one character and
sort of unlocking
better loot as you go along or does it
feel more like you're doing higher level
missions and then through those missions
you're finding better loot
you find better loot through higher
level missions
there's a little bit of a disparity with
like a level one i kind of had the same
thing i found with destiny like a level
one gun against a level one character
didn't really feel that different from a
level 20 gun let with a level 20
character right yeah because we played
both a starting character and a level 20
character the game didn't feel like it
had changed that much but you know i
didn't get to experience the journey in
the storyline that happens in between 1
and 20. so
again mechanically i thought the game
was competent
it's not the thing that's going to carry
it like destiny it sounds like it as
opposed to destiny which i remember
kevin's review back in i guess it was
like 2014 at this age was one of the
biggest things he said peter was that it
was a game that was sort of bereft of
place like and we've subsequently found
out that the story had actually been
ripped out of the game um do you think
that's important to a a co-op like
shooter like this does that did it
matter in destiny that it didn't really
feel fleshed out and do you think it
could be to the benefit of a game like
the division because you know maybe
maybe that's what people like about
games like borderlands i don't know i
think it really matters and you look at
something like destiny that's set in
sort of like these alien worlds it's
easy to like and i say easy real you
know in very limited terms but it's easy
to sort of concoct these fantastical
things that don't exist
right and just out of your imagination
and say this is what the world is but
for the division you know it's using
manhattan right like
people know manhattan contemporary time
yeah yeah so i think it's important in
the sense that it's it's grounding the
game in something that we can relate to
and as you made it sound they actually
do a good job of that which i i think
that's important for any game to do is
is to to draw you into the world um you
know or else it is just about mechanics
yeah but a game needs a little bit of
soul i think that's what people sort of
gravitated towards when they saw the e3
20 13 stuff was that oh yes like look
this like feels different because it's
like oh it's contemporary and it feels
like it's grounded and it feels like i
can reach and sort of touch it like yeah
a lot of these games can and for me like
growing up with harsh winters like in
and around new york yeah like for me it
was like cool like i could i could see
this happening sort of right like if
this [ __ ] hit the fan
like
yeah like i was like i want to be i want
to experience that because i've walked
those streets and to see them empty but
then like
there's a dude hiding behind a car door
like waiting to take you out like i it
looks good to me and so i think it's
important in that regard um the gameplay
like i have so many questions and it's
not so much about what it does or
doesn't have but it's just how it feels
that's that's the one thing i'm really
wondering let me there's a couple of
questions they're coming in from the
twitch chat and a couple of already bank
to sort of touch on that and if i don't
get around to it feel free to throw your
own atoms as well uh but a lot of people
are asking a lot of questions about it
feels like you've sort of tempered your
expectation and that's the conversation
we're having whereas the internet is
very much like is this
is this what i think it was so some of
those questions are thomas rock's
echoing a lot of what people are saying
in the twitch show right now impressions
on whether or not enemies are a bit
bullet spongy that's one of the things
that came across in the gameplay was man
you were shooting a guy in the head a
lot he doesn't really seem like he's
reacting in a realistic way
you know i saw a clip where there was
five or six
just hooded people wandering towards you
know not taking cover and
soaking up bullets like it's going out
of fashion
is that the experience of playing the
division uh i would have two things to
say about that i think one it's a
double-edged sword because it's a
contemporary setting you're not shooting
aliens or like you know locusts or
something huge that feels like it could
take a lot of bullets right so it is a
little
weird when you're pumping a dude with a
hoodie full of rounds and he's not
reacting at all yeah and i think a lot
of
a lot of the disparity between what i'd
like the shooting to be and what it is
came down to just the enemies not
reacting very present right like they
don't seem aware that they're getting
shot a lot of times
and they don't react like they're
getting shot and i think those are
potentially fixable things
um on the other hand i will say that the
preview build that we all played
including youtubers and everybody who
was there yeah um was three people
playing and the game we were told scales
to difficulty so i do wonder i think a
lot more people
are going to be playing this as a single
player experience than people think
because you won't run into other people
randomly in the world outside of the
spawn zone that's an interesting
question owen o'connell asked what will
this game offer to someone who's playing
solo could you play because that's the
main reason i dropped off destiny was
like i got to whatever i think i'm like
super low like level 15 or 16 or
something and i just thought oh god i'm
really feel like my experience of being
handicapped because i'm not playing with
other people so is this a game do you
think you could play solo the question
is how well does a game scale to a solo
player we didn't see that um it was very
hard with three people and i will say
that the the challenge was there for
three people and you will probably have
to work with your friends
if they do the same thing and
to an individual i don't see how you
would survive on normal difficulty but
again we didn't get to see the game
scale down to a single person
but yeah like that was one of the
reasons why i'd taper off destiny over
time too and you know i would come back
to it as my friends came back to it and
then taper off as they tapered off
whereas this game
you know end game content aside that's a
whole other discussion
it probably will be a little bit more
friendly to an individual person
actually probably a lot more friendly to
an individual person destiny was i guess
yeah it'll dodge some of those problems
critical reviews asks is it pretty easy
to group up with friends and then bob
johnson and eddie asking a question a
lot of people in the chat are max party
size so is was it easy to to get
involved with other people and what was
it was it is it for the max
yeah four players uh co-op um
i i think in the in the zone you spawn
it was pretty easy i can't remember it
was just a couple button presses after
writing at somebody
um or somebody on your friends list
it's a little bit disappointing that
you're not going to just run into people
out in the world because i always like
that about
kind of just organically meeting up with
people to share a moment and then
dissipating
and you won't get that outside of the
dark zone but there is the dark zone
yeah i will say that the dark zone is
probably more true to their original
vision than any other aspect of this
game
it feels like kind of the day z meets
i don't know it sounds like an instance
like it's just a multiplayer instance or
something where you're kind of well
actually i guess the opposite of what an
instance is in that it's like you're
booting into like an area where you can
run into random people i mean it looks
like what they show to e3 2013 at least
not to keep holding the game accountable
to its original vision but like that's
that's what i wanted to play right
that's what i think people in the chat
wanted to play and i think that's where
people are all going to end up too as a
matter of fact i think you're going to
want to get there as early as possible
because i don't know how they're going
to stats balance um or whether they're
going to stat balance at all for weapons
like i don't know if a bunch of level
20s are just going to dominate or like
30s are going to dominate that area
so i have a feeling a lot of people are
going to check out the open world and
then depending on how
gated it is
um because there are gates they're gates
with
virus masks right and there are level 20
mask over above only yeah
how big was the dark zone
it was a i think it was almost a third
of the map okay okay actually and then
that goes into a question a lot of
people coffee jesus in the twitch chat
asking do you think ubisoft snapping
brooklyn off the division smacks of
destiny trying to make more money from
the game later and i guess
echoing what mr mazek said can you
compare the division's map size to
another game so we have some sort of
perspective how big is this game and do
you think
it can still be playable at the size it
is now or still worthwhile
the unanswered question so the short
answer is if i just had to just freaking
snowball it i would say
it's about the size of destiny without
loading screens so if you just took all
the planets and the original destiny and
smooshed them together that's what it
kind of feels remove loading screens
yeah it's comparable to that size um we
spent three hours in just one like
i don't know 10 square block area
doing missions and stuff so it's sizable
you know the density of content is
really what matters yeah and also
because it's in a city with skyscrapers
we have no idea what kind of verticality
the game will have right i mean it's
three dimensions so like we know there's
an underground i don't know if there's
any skyscrapers that you can go into
um
so yeah it's a three-dimensional map and
we just don't know how much of that
space they're using but it didn't feel
like
this was a game that would
be
critically hampered from having
brooklyn off the map or having let's
just say an extra 50 or 100 more map but
did it feel like it was sort of
substantial
if you i know it's a super difficult
because i'm asking you off a three hour
demo to [ __ ] tell me how how big the
game is i'm not i'm not very concerned
about
map size i guess if you're coming as
like a skyrim player like no you're not
getting
you're not getting anything like that
um
again i think you're worried what you're
actually worried when you ask that
question is about content density yeah
and whether there's enough for you to do
in the world yeah the quail is asking
can you see division having any
longevity problems so i guess that's
probably the longevity
right now the only
proposed longevity i can see is in the
dark zone
whether the dark zone ends up being
like daisy or whether the dark zone ends
up just being generic
like pvp rice yeah we don't know yet um
that's where the best loot is that's
where all the high level players are
going
if you hit level 30 they actually have
like a dedicated dark zone
for the highest level player vip club
yeah
um i am concerned though i don't know
how matchmaking is going to work in the
dark zone and
if you
start this game a week late like i don't
know if a bunch of level 20s are just
going to stop you right the second you
get in there yeah and i don't know if
you can wander at solo because if i got
three guys and you're by yourself with
some sick loot i'm just gonna take you
out yeah i have no motivation to not do
that yeah pick them off easy i have
peter you got any questions for aaron
did you get that sweet hat
i feel like for any of us to like you
were kind of pointing out to really like
speak about this game in definite terms
we have to play it for a long amount of
time and that's just what i want to do
i'm
i just when can i play it
yeah i guess i yeah as somebody who has
at least had like a smidgen of what that
experience is they're all looking
forward to it
how did you feel coming away from having
some time with the division did you feel
disappointed did you feel like you had
to reset your expectation did you feel
like
it was fun in a different way uh well
yeah what did you think i think actually
uh eric tay in our office put it best
where
he always does yeah
the expectation kind of tanked after
last year's e3 right so my expectations
were properly lowered going into this
i think
i see a fun game i didn't see a like
in the three hours he played it it
wasn't fantastic it was totally
competent
i could see having a lot of fun
grouping up with friends and playing
through
and i did see some like in the echo
sequences i actually did see some
genuinely really good writing like with
the the rikers prisoners
um there was a great moment where one of
them was like torturing a guard and the
guard says to him like
you know dude i'm not just a number i'm
not just a uniform i'm a guy and the
riker's guard the rikers guy says him
great well now you know how i feel
so like there were some good moments
like that but there were also moments
where
some of the main characters were
kind of like cheese balling it
why is dan reichert taking prisoners
thinking the same thing so yeah good
three hours with it it was good but not
great and i'm looking forward to
digging much deeper into this game and
seeing what the deeper content is yeah
it's there pretty soon uh first week of
march is that right yeah and then alpha
march 8th march 8th is the unofficial
right now okay
when is the mobile
companion that might have been cut i
think oh god oh my god i want to get
that drone to come in
just a super loud [ __ ] with a gun on
it have you seen videos of them trying
to put guns on drones have you seen that
there you go yeah the division probably
has the tech aaron samson thank you so
much for coming in telling us all about
your time with the division thank you i
really appreciate your time uh you folks
who are watching this uh live thank you
so much by the way for supplying us for
questions for you guys watching this on
gamespot or youtube after the fact and
you have any questions uh by all means
feel free to put them in the comments
below we'll try and get to them and let
us know what you think about the
division are you excited for it are you
stemming your expectation put your
thoughts in the comments below
all right mr sampson i'm gonna swap you
out for a certain mr waters who i think
uh should be outside that door we'll do
a little drumroll find out thanks so
much man what are you working on this
week actually that people should sort of
keep an eye on in the next day or so
i don't know if i can actually say great
all right
embargoes on gamespot.com but i'm
looking forward to your division beta
next week yes i will be playing for sure
awesome and we'll have more hot division
content up on games i [ __ ] said
content as well you love content content
can we invent some technology where the
minute i say conte it just
it's like redacted
it's like like a black bar comes across
my mouth and then
i don't can't say anything what do you
think about christopher i think aaron
sampson's been sitting at this desk you
don't talk
twice you guys have called him out for
not being as tall as you i'm sorry
i'm sorry aaron's a great guy
just not as tall as he just not as he's
not as a lot of things as me he's not as
fat as me he's not as irish as me he's
not as much of a
prolific lover as me
he's married danny
well then i take it back he has three
children who you call him not prolific
man that's a good point that's a good
point uh
how you doing guys
i'm still good you still good
we've talked later things haven't
changed hello uh we've talked a lot
about video games today uh let's uh
let's talk about something else for a
second chris waters you're here you
watch some movies over the weekend i
watched some movie films over the
weekend peter brown has been known to
watch a movie that isn't anime
and the oscars are on pretty soon
nominations have come out not without a
little degree of controversy as well
we'll get to that later uh but first of
all i want to talk uh about this is kind
of like what we talk about around the
office when we're not talking about
games especially this time of year so
oscar season right what are the the
movies that are um nominated in best
picture what are the ones we think are
good and i always find this interesting
because the oscars especially best film
is always this weird mix of oh yeah of
course and what is that like i've never
heard of it before so let's go down to
the list and see which of these movies
sort of lit us on fire uh first one up
mad max fury road uh george miller's
long
time coming mad max sequel
you know whenever you try and go back
and make a a new version of an old movie
or or of an old series it's always you
know super risky business this is like
easily the best mad max warfare for me
it's so good
uh chris what do you think of it i i
love that movie i mean i
i like to go to the movies i don't do it
terribly often um but i don't like
i'm not a dude who ever like watches a
movie twice right i don't go to the
theater multiple times and i don't like
i don't own a lot of blu-rays i don't
like ask for them for gifts or anything
but i asked for mad max this year for
fury road because i was like i need to
see this movie again and i need to be
able to watch it again and again because
it was just like so
vivid and alive and breathtaking and
like intriguing throughout like every
frame and i it lit me on fire when i saw
it in the theater and i i watched it
over the holiday break again and it's so
so good it's super dense they always say
the movies that make all that really big
money like that crazy star wars money
are ones that get off multiple uh
viewing and i saw this twice in the
cinema as well peter you founded my max
i thought it was amazing i mean i i saw
mad max movies growing up as a kid and
they were always kind of this kitschy
thing that you kept in the background
like oh yeah remember those movies this
was like
guess what this is what mad max should
have been all along and it was as you
said dense you took the words out of my
mouth
dense with characters wonderful
cinematography wonderful sets
um there were there was only a few
things that bothered me and even then
those like it just took another like
scene change for me to forget all about
all right um i thought it was amazing
and uh yeah i've seen it multiple times
and i think it should just exist in
isolation i don't know that i want
anymore yeah well it doesn't seem like
you're going to get anything right
because yeah yeah miller subsequently
come out and said that plans to do the
two other ones are now not happening but
yeah but i think this movie should exist
on its own and just be this great
awesome little yeah looking forward to
showing this to my kids in 20 years from
now and i'm saying they see this that's
what they said the world would be like
and here we are and next one up looking
back to the past brooklyn i'm guessing
i'm the only one that's seen this danny
i haven't seen it
have you seen this what's brooklyn
brooklyn is uh circa ronan or swearsay
if you're an american reading her name
uh it's a story of this uh girl who like
a familiar tale for me a girl who moves
from uh actually a town that's about 20
miles from where i grew up in wexford uh
moves to bro isn't that all towns in
ireland
uh it's her experience sort of moving to
america feeling homesick going home
falling in love and it's it's a
it was a wonderful i really enjoyed this
movie not just because uh the creators
of which amanda posey and fenola dwyer
shout out to the clan um not that clan
uh not just because it was it's a super
great irish movie or a movie about
ireland in so many ways uh but it's a
it's a really fascinating sort of
timepiece i love movies that really
capture old times well and i've actually
never been to new york in my life so i
can't say that it captured new york
particularly well but life in ireland
and the irish scenes for me was
completely spot on to what i remember
and what i remember people telling me
about my parents so this is like a
1900s yes this is like 19
i want to say 50s okay uh yeah sort of
uh
immigration immigra immigrant move
post-war yes okay around time yeah super
good i enjoyed it a lot i was actually
surprised to see it though to be
completely honest on this i thought it
was sort of like just one of those good
movies that won't get recognized outside
of it so moving on from that i guess to
something though i'm guessing we've all
seen the martian
you seen it all right peter what are you
thinking of martial matt damon on a
marsh spoilers there's no martians maybe
it was the character that i built in my
head when i was reading the book but
matt damon's portrayal of the lead
character i can't remember his name now
johnny martian johnny martian
just i it just really kind of rubbed me
the wrong way all right i'm not getting
best picture vibe from this film at all
uh i i
from the list just looking at it before
this
i didn't realize that it was nominated i
don't think it should be yeah um
i thought his portrayal was
not great i thought that the film didn't
focus on enough things in the book that
made it an interesting read for me right
which was the sort of thought processes
that the that he went through when
trying to figure out okay how do i fix
things how do i make this happen matt
damon was just like um i got it no
problem you know like did you see that
now so ding ding ding like it's like
like
okay i get it you're this like charming
clever dude but what about the struggle
you're going through like there were a
couple mishaps that threw him off his
you know
his comfy chair but like
like really like that's all the struggle
you're going to go through during this
entire journey it just didn't it didn't
didn't hit me chris i remember you were
talking about it um uh
about the how process really worked in
that movie how like it was a great movie
about the scientific method as much as
it was about the reality of what was
happening yeah that's why you like that
movie i liked i was drawn to that movie
and i haven't i hadn't read the book so
my perspective was a little different
than peter's uh and i think that
it is a movie that like
it's really cool that he's just like
shoveling a bunch of poop and then
putting a bunch of poop on the floor
like right that's not a heroic act but
it this movie makes it feel like it it
makes it feel like
okay like writing a you know how many
like chicken teriyaki dinners you got
out on a white board like that's a smart
thing that a person does and i think so
much of
science and so much of that kind of
uh expertise that has led to the world
that we live in in so many ways is like
is kind of boring you know like when you
look at it on the face of it it's like a
lot of like process work a lot of
grinding through and so i think the
martian did a great job of distilling
that in a way where it kind of honors
those otherwise sort of
seemingly mundane actions and elevates
them because of the setting and to me
the setting was one of the standouts i
mean i'm not a guy who like looks at
pictures that the rover sends back from
mars and is like
dude dude i love that
i think they look cool and i'm
interested like on a intellectual level
but
the like vistas that the visual effects
team created for the martian made that
planet look
like
fascinating and intriguing and
foreboding and beautiful to me in a way
that you know actual pictures of it
haven't which is fine it's movie magic
but like i don't know i felt that pull
and i felt that connection with like our
actual space efforts
um you know despite the fact that it
ends on this like
crazy rocket ship sequence dude
i'm going out to get him like you know
it it does those action movie tropes and
it falls into that uh in a way that i
think was ended up being off-putting for
you
i i mean
a lot of people in the chat sort of
echoing that as well
like i kind of feel the same way that
it's it's a really great like i really
enjoy watching it but it just doesn't
feel like it's like one of the seven
best movies of the year uh but just like
a great use case in terms of how to film
that type of process like like wow like
how the hell did you make growing
vegetables interesting in that way there
were subtleties in the book that it just
might sound like such like any door yeah
like anyone talking about any book made
into a movie ever but they but they
totally gloss legit they totally glossed
over like the the finer points of his
journey to present this
like this matt damon yeah all right
let's talk about a different book has
anyone read or seen
is it the rumor room it's room it's room
the room is the tommy wiseau thing
that's a different situation
throw forks at the screen um have any of
you read the book
no i heard about the book and was when
it was getting a lot of press and i was
really intrigued by it yeah that's why i
wanted to see the movie and i saw it
yesterday actually
i've seen it as well but i have not read
the book okay what was your experience
of it what you think we're not getting
into spoilers again because there's
another one though well i don't know
because if you look at a trailer like do
you consider what's shown in the trailer
spoilers maybe because we're showing it
right now
sure all right so yeah you see in the
trailer that like the premise of this
movie is that there's this woman and her
child and they're they're they've been
she's been abducted they are trapped in
a room they can't get out that's their
whole world uh and then they do get out
so the movie is about like the movie
covers both scenarios yes the before and
after
and
oh man is it so fascinating the way like
what if you had to raise a child like
this child the only thing they know
about the world is this room yeah like
you that's why that's why the fact that
the book and the movie are titled room
it's like earth yes you know like it's
not like we're like this is earth this
is room like this is all of existence
and they talk the way that like you see
through the mom and through the kid the
like world she's had to create and then
the way that he's interpreted the world
and the way that he's built his world
like it's amazing and then how he has to
deal with oh no it's like plato's cave
basically it's like oh it's not just the
shadows dancing on the wall this is the
world and how does your brain
compensate for that how do you figure
that out yeah once he's out and then all
of a sudden like the world is more of a
reality and like he's squinting all the
time and that makes you think you know
there's a scene with a doctor and you're
like oh my god like
yes like this kid seems totally like
normal and functional but
what if what it like he hasn't been
exposed to germs or like varying like
there's only one source of natural light
in his house and he thought that
television was like this weird ethereal
place where everything like didn't exist
like it was all it was all cartoons i
thought that that kid did such a
fantastic job yeah great yeah throughout
that whole movie and i think brie larson
who also got the nominated for best
actress i think she did a good job i
feel like it's a kind of a soft
nomination for best actress because what
you really see like the times that you
really see
like she shows you her struggle in some
ways but then
in the latter half of the movie where
you're seeing the adjustment to the
world outside
you're
really seeing it through the kids eyes
yeah a lot i mean the book was mostly
apparently
told through the kids yeah and there so
you don't really hear his internal
monologue and so i think that like
i don't you know i don't i'm not sure
about that best actress nomination but
like the for best picture i think that
it's like such a fascinating drama such
an intriguing
story and that comes from the adaptation
but yeah
that was a that was a stand out for me
we need to get through a couple of more
of these as well has anyone seen bridges
spies
no no tom hanks steven spielberg it's
like oh okay it's a tommax steven
spielberg movie of course it's getting a
nomination it kind of feels like that my
wife saw it and she was not a fan right
uh but like it does
i mean i don't really know what it's
about i'm sure it's a perfectly fine
drama cold war might be fun entertaining
for entertaining
planes crashing apparently
ejecting from tom hanks castaway he
lands on it no he's all right don't
worry about it wilson gets promoted
generally
let us know in the comments what you
think of uh bridge of spies then since
uh we we don't have any experts on the
panel here
um uh a movie
i think did you see over the weekend the
revenants you did a double bill of room
and revenant i did that's a tough
afternoon it was a really good time the
old amc i haven't seen revenant i tried
to catch it over the weekend and
couldn't unfortunately have you haven't
seen it on either feeder have you no
i've seen it oh you've seen it okay
perfect mary's outside with er er last
week was talking a lot about it as well
she was interested in it but had some
critiques as well uh peter first of all
then what did you think of the revenant
um the easiest way for me to
characterize it is that it's half an
hour shorter than the cut of hateful
eight that i saw okay i felt at least an
hour longer okay
um
i i was less impressed with the film
than i had hoped uh the
the constant struggle that uh dicaprio's
character is going through
begins to like not wear on you because
he's struggling but because it's like i
feel like i just watched that scene like
they changed the the setting they
changed the problem he's dealing with
but it's still the same kind of issue
like he's not getting to where he needs
to get um and then i felt the resolution
in the third act just came way too fast
and the payoff wasn't there for me the
thing i had been waiting for was a
letdown um chris you came away from her
thinking like oh this is a really
beautifully sharp movie but again yeah
but you're in these beautiful wilds of
canada how i mean like
it's not that hard to make that area
seem beautiful on that note just a quick
sidebar like i was looking at the
nominees for best seminar cinematography
which of course the revenant is one i
watched another one of those this
weekend sicario which is about the
border uh and the drug war uh between us
and mexico yes
the cinematography and like you want to
take like banff national park and make
it look beautiful no problem you want to
take the mexican border at juarez that
has like shanty towns on one side prefab
houses on the other and a big ugly ass
steel wall in between and make that look
beautiful and like menacing but
intriguing and like foreboding in all
these wonderful ways sicario does that
and like it it was a great watch for and
that the cinematography was so sadly
sadly not nominated for uh was emily
blunton as well
yes she was uh yeah didn't get a whole
lot of nominations most of them were
production related but back to the
revenant uh i feel like this is one of
those nominations where they're like man
you guys went out into the snow
and acted a lot that must have been real
hard grunted a lot here's your
nomination like leo dicaprio his
performance in that i have no doubt that
was very difficult for him and no no
doubt that was taxing for him as an
actor but like
he plays an animal throughout the whole
thing right he's not a human because
he's so messed up that he is like
debased to his basic survival instincts
which is fine that's a certain kind of
narrative but a survival story
like you need tension
for it to really hit home and never
would did i doubt that he was going to
survive until
dawn
come on no no no no no seriously halfway
through no no no no no no no no no no
this is one but that's
from the get-go you look at the movie
trailer no no i don't so like okay and
you can't assume that i'm sorry you
can't assume anyone else uh all right so
prove your point we're not talking about
as plot issues fair enough but it was
all right so this was my other problem
with the revenant which was
if like it is if you were talking about
how you like historical movies movies to
create old times feel like you're it's
the thing it does a fantastic job of
creating of this like wild west the wild
north between between like american fur
traders french fur traders native
americans like it creates this
incredible scene there
and sets the stage and all the native
american tribes are represented in
diverse and interesting ways like
there's a couple different factions at
play and then they like have this great
chance to make this drama in this
setting with a native american league
character
and they cast leo dicaprio like it just
felt like it was
it was almost there like it could have
been something special but it fell short
in a few ways to me and you know it's a
monumental film in many ways but like uh
interesting another one that we're kind
of lukewarm a bit on the the panel and
we've got two more to get into uh the
big short uh this is about the financial
crisis obviously another movie about
that i believe it's adapted from the
same writer who wrote money ball and
based on the book as well anyone seen
this at all big big
a lot of famous actors and actresses in
this one
the big short talk segment uh
it's just going to be a short talk great
try to make it there you go let us know
what you think about the big shorts
whether adam mckay should win best
director or gets best movie uh let us
know in the comments below and i guess
the last movie this is one that i
watched recently um michael sugar's up
for a win on this for uh best film i
hadn't really heard of it until quite
recently spotlight this is uh
michael keaton and friends oh yeah and
the i guess the boston globes reporting
on the uh child molestation
epidemic that was uh with the catholic
church uh stemming i guess from what was
going on in boston from their
perspective but then led to what was
essentially a global problem uh i didn't
really know much about what was
happening in boston around that time
because ireland was going through the
same thing um
yeah so at the end of the movie there
there is a part where they show here are
the cities in which there are this was a
problem connecticut was on oh really
yeah and there was like a bunch like i
feel like somewhere close to a dozen
irish towns were in there as well uh on
all the all the
cities they mentioned a really really
great movie like obviously it's about
something that is incredibly difficult
and heartfelt i think what's interesting
about it is that it is predominantly
told from the s
from the side of the media like
they obviously interview victims and
they talk to priests and whatnot but it
is told from the side of we have this
story we're researching it we're you
know it's like the de it's happening
around the same times as like
you know these papers are shutting down
like 9 11 happens in the middle so it
doesn't happen if they don't have the
sort of it's not the right time to
publish the story anymore we're worried
about someone else picking up the story
where we need to get them like it's it's
not we're just reporting on a story this
this is the story that we need to nail
the church to the wall so that it
doesn't happen again so it's like
it's an incredible story it's only told
from that perspective which i think is
probably too it's credit in a way like
in that way it becomes a little like i
enjoy it more i think more because of
being like involved somewhat in in the
press and whatnot like i enjoy that
aspect of it at least um i think maybe
other people who aren't interested in
the process of press writing might think
it's a little bit self-indulgent with
the press maybe a little bit um or like
focuses too much on that and not enough
from the victims or the reality of the
story perhaps uh but it's great i really
enjoyed it i thought it was a fantastic
it did what you were saying about how
when a movie does it right it doesn't
feel long uh this movie is i think it's
two hours 10 15 minutes yeah something
and it breezed by it was uh really
wonderful and yeah i know it's great
when you watch a movie and you feel like
holy [ __ ] like that's that's kind of
like a that's i'm glad i watched us
because like this is something that we
should not forget about yeah this sort
of stuff got people got away with doing
this awful
[ __ ] for let's say centuries uh finally
get called out and you know it's been
over a decade now but lest we not forget
important lessons um those are the
movies so i guess the last question for
you guys the big short mad max fury road
uh josh shaw has sent me a link there
apparently miller will be going back and
making more mad max movies uh article
post reese more recently so we'll see
you back so hey so hey thanks josh
the big short mad max fury road brooklyn
the martian the revenant bridge of spies
room spotlight peter what gets your win
off that list med max all right
of the half of these that i've seen
mad max is my choice for sure and uh i
really liked spotlight a lot
but
uh of the movies that i've watched here
i'd also say mad max fury road wouldn't
it be [ __ ] great if an action movie
well that just shows you how good that
movie is on many levels on so many like
like the the sort of the action the
cinematography the shooting the the like
the subtext like everything about it is
just like they just needed let's get
targeted
more guitar guy
he married he married one of the
uh what's your name again i forget the
name of one of the wives or whatever her
name is she was elvis presley's
granddaughter is that right they got
married
dude that guy did a little dude i got a
question for you about these nominees
all right uh one that was not missing
that i feel was missing from the best
picture nomination list yeah inside out
by pixar oh yeah you think i think so i
saw that at pixar and i sorry god that's
just the worst thing that i've ever said
i saw that at pixar
danny it's okay i'm so sorry it's okay i
saw that i'm meant to say i'm such a big
pixar fan and i love those movies and i
was really lucky that i got to go see it
there and actually i thought that was
good
that was a good picture that was a good
picture it wasn't it wasn't like it
didn't blow my mind oh my god all right
so i watched this and that's not too
much we're running a bit late long
enough okay anyways i think that the way
that this movie is insightful and
illuminating about the human condition
and about human emotion and about the
way emotions work inside of our brains
is phenomenal and i think that it's you
know the stories of teachers and
psychiatrists using it to like help
educate people right warm my heart but
like i watched this with my wife and her
mother and they we like had lost uh my
father-in-law in the past couple of
years and like
this like the way that that movie deals
with like grief and sadness and
it was like we were all it we discussed
it afterwards and like how how true it
was in our lives then you know how it
resonates with stuff that we encountered
in our childhood it just
the the writing and the way that they
brought it to life i thought was
phenomenal and worthy of high praise uh
we've already run over super long on
this but i think that we can't talk
about this without also talking about uh
what's happening in relation to you know
with
not not to say that like this is
something we should only talk about on
martin luther king weekend but
especially um and with everything that's
happening at the moment sort of around
the country obviously there's a lot of
eyes on the fact that this is a super
white nominees list across the board
jada pickett smith and spike lee are
going to not be attending the oscars uh
the oscar the academy's put out its own
press release about this um
you know we're three white guys here
we're not the people to be really
talking about this but let's just take a
moment and say like
what there were some really great movies
starring african-american actors or some
about african-american stories which did
not get highlighted this year uh the
ones that sort of stand out to me i
think we're looking at at the moment is
creed which i did not see a lot of
people telling me that this is not just
a great rocky movie but this is a great
movie yeah it's true you've seen it yeah
yeah i really liked it like i
the kind of like the old man max films
the rocky films for me were like this
little joke that you'd like reference
once in a while yeah just go back to it
you'll have it laugh kind of hokey let
me have fun and great and yeah this this
was like a solid like
you know kind of coming of age story for
this kid who grew up like in the
splendor of his father's success
figuring out who he was and finding his
own success and defining that in his own
terms
and then sort of linking back to this
old series and it did it in a way that
wasn't really like ham-fisted like rocky
was this really
like this dude with problems you know
like he's by the end of the movie he's
still not resolved his issues and uh but
that's fine uh because michael b jordan
the the kid who played adonis creed uh
was so good like at his role is so
believable
um and so good as as a companion like
with his girlfriend i thought that was a
really honest relationship and it was
interesting to see
that blossom alongside this sort of like
film that's based on fighting
a couple of other movies that people
have been pointing at beasts of no
nation um i haven't seen yet but one i
did see uh as a massive nwa fan i was
actually kind of a little worried about
this i thought like oh you know they're
gonna it's a kind of a weird story to
try and tell especially like you're
gonna use you know
ex singers like the person who's in the
movie sons of players just so much about
uh straight out of compton seemed like
it wasn't going to work man this was a
[ __ ] solid movie i like absolutely
adored it chris did you see it no
unfortunately uh peter have you seen it
it's super eyeball i watched it i
watched it on on a plane
on the way back from the was it the
pixar private jet down yeah
and i thought it was amazing you know
giamatti's in it and and it's got about
like all all the actors in it playing
what it did actually was tell a side of
that story that i didn't realize because
i was so young when all that was
happening and i sort of was an nwa fan
after the fact was that man they were so
young like those
dudes were were like straight out of
school like they were just they were
still teenagers they were young men when
that was happening and i guess the sort
of the movement that they
that they lit was didn't seem weird to
them because that was the reality they
were living in but it seemed weird to
the rest of the world right so like it
was it wasn't like there were some
revolutionaries who were taking this
dangerous idea and trying to force it on
people that was just the reality they
lived in and it seemed completely normal
for them to talk about it and i think as
somebody who sort of only ever saw one
side of that conversation through their
music to sort of see
what i saw in this movie wasn't just an
echo of their music it was actually
really
putting context to what was happening
during that time which someone
especially growing up in ireland who
didn't really know a lot about uh you
know civil rights movement or about the
sort of rodney king episodes and all
that sort of stuff uh was definitely
growing up it was like a massive massive
insight into that world and it still
kind of [ __ ] sucks right that like
they were watching like selma it was in
our movie i watched recently we're
watching all these movies about these
you know these poignant times in the
world where we've learned lessons in the
same way that like i was watching a
movie about catholic priests getting
away with molesting you know like movies
about these times but like literally
it's still happening like when we're and
we're talking about like
it's like art and life are just like
it's like it's almost ridiculous that
you know we're in the situation and i'm
sure the academy is full of a lot of you
know
old hollywood people so you're talking
predominantly caucasian predominantly
male so it's sort of a shame that we're
not like in the uk they have the the
mobile words which is like specifically
to
highlight uh people of color is art and
music specifically um we don't you know
that's probably not the right way to go
about doing this sort of stuff but like
you kind of feel for all these artists
when they're making all this stuff and
it doesn't get recognized just because
people aren't in touch with us they
don't see it it just seems to me like
you know you you know i we're all white
dudes here right yeah you know we're
used to seeing ourselves in all you
we're used to seeing ourselves
represented
uh in a variety of ways you know there's
not just like the the one like one or
two great white dude movies this year
like there's a lot yeah because such a
lion's share of movies are made with
white dudes in like really prominent
roles uh i think that when you hear
people talking especially women and
people of color talking about how
representation matters to them and
being represented in you know on screen
in awards how that's so vital and so
important you can't ignore that you have
to listen you have to trust that that is
that that is a real powerful thing
because it's not something i've ever
struggled with being able to look at a
screen and see an image of myself or an
image of how i might imagine myself it's
like an alien concept yeah right it's
just not so so to me i trust those
people and i trust that that you know
that and i read what they say and it's
compelling and it's heartbreaking and
then you go turn around and see star
wars and that's two stars of that yeah a
woman and a black guy and they are
fantastic and sure say what you will
about star wars being the name
associated with it but like
that movie is great because those two
are great in it and like that's
you know
money money talks all right well money
is talking so like let's not use that
argument anymore for sure the biggest
movie uh opening of all time there you
go boom let's you know
see what happens uh interesting was that
snell dexter last point on this star
wars since you bring it up oh for best
film yeah
it's a pretty good film i don't know
it's a really i mean it's really great i
had a great time better than the martian
i would say yes
let us know in the comments if you think
star wars the force awakens is better
than the martian uh and uh yeah let us
know what you think about the nominees
what you think is gonna win uh and what
do you think uh yeah some movies that
maybe you liked that weren't um
mentioned at all in the in the uh
nominations let us know in the comments
below all right i ran out a little bit
but that was fun i mean we took on a big
topic let's be real that's true yeah i
was talking about the best movies of the
year there's a lot of movies i know i
was like saying i will only talk about
best movies you want to talk about like
actors nominees or cinematography or
anything it'll be super short no problem
and then i came in and i have like my
whole nominee list here and i'm
scrolling back for them like oh yeah
yeah sound editing
i like it great to have you here last
question is leo gonna get his best actor
award wait has he not gotten one before
no he's never gotten an oscar really
[ __ ] he should stop trying i think he
shouldn't for this
no man he shouldn't just like he didn't
he didn't do a bad job in the movie by
any stretch but it just was like do the
beach too there's your
beached
more beach hardwood of vengeance gilbert
grapes all grown-ups perform beach
before we leave i wanted to uh open up
some questions to twitch if anyone has
anything i kind of want to ask you guys
why you've been playing at the moment
what you played over the weekend i asked
aaron already you said you were just
watching anime and adaption live-action
adaptions of anime i watched uh raroni
kenshin is an anime series about a
samurai who was a merciless killer in
the time of feudal japan okay but when
they found peace oh yeah the
imperialists mohammed at a war he uh
yeah so he decided to
have the blade on his sword reversed and
fight only to defend those when they
needed help okay uh and to never kill
again uh the anime is very long-winded
and i liked it when i was a teenager but
not so much but they made three movies
okay that like in japanese huh in
japanese yeah yeah they encapsulate
pretty much all 95 episodes of the tv
show and they're really good like i
really liked them a lot um and a
character who struggles with
who he is and what because he was like
sold as a slave and then sort of taken
on by this guy and betrayed his teacher
to go fight the good fight ended up
killing people see him struggle with
that stuff it's actually a great story
even though it's based on an anime i
also watched the ace attorney movie what
yeah
i didn't know there was one it's done by
takeshi mike the
you can tell it's done by him each is
great it's not a great movie no it's a
shame chris you playing on it over there
again did i play anything yeah yeah man
i played rocket league
2016's game of the year look he's got
that shirt and he's got that shirt
uh games look great i played rocket
league i'm working on my uh wall play
because like once you're up on the wall
like i really like i jump off and then i
need to like jump off and then go into
an aerial that's what i'm working on as
like how that's another dimension to
aerial play uh in rocket league also uh
playing some witcher i'm working through
that skellige situation wow uh which
i've been pl i've played that game a lot
i'm like level 20 something i don't know
but so i've like finished a lot of the
mainland quests to this point and now
doing skellige stuff and like sailing
around and have you completed a main
story yet no that's great
that game is so big it's so dumb uh and
i also have watched in the past what's
today the 19th 19 days like four and a
half seasons of homeland because oh wow
did you just start from the start yeah
because phil and i got a nasty cold like
the fur like right on right now we all
have it great so i was out for like a
significant amount of time um but yeah
so we just like got showtime streaming
through hulu plus and have watched
almost all of that entire show and
i don't know what it is like the first
season i was like all right and then he
gets a good thing at the end it's like
oh all right season two and two happens
to see dude
and then it kind of maybe and then like
i gave it three i haven't watched any of
this season because i'm like nah [ __ ] it
man there's oh we're on the fifth season
now there's five yeah maybe i watched
four i think claire danes is awesome i
think that uh her like on like i think
her that character is really fascinating
in the way that she's like
super badass and is like portrayed as
such not just from like what she does
but from the way that everyone else
views her in the show uh but she's still
got problems that she's got so many
really big problems like sometimes
you're like yeah she's gonna do it and
other times you're like no
i think i find her character so
unbelievable that she gets so far
over the line and comes back from it
yeah i keep thinking no you should have
at least like thrown yourself off a
bridge one of these times like she's
just
how does it act yeah because the wonder
of television totally um i want to give
a shout out to i'd never played i was i
played revan at the video game over the
weekend oh which is the long dark
the uh roguelike you crash in that rogue
like sorry the like persistent death you
crash in the canadian wilderness and
have to survive
as long as you can but before you i
don't think you could not die in that
game i'm pretty sure you just officially
died you eventually died so i lasted for
like three days but you're literally
like
finding you know scraps of food and like
lighting a fire with like stuff that
you've broken outside in like the minus
20 degrees outdoors and like i did this
thing where i was like okay i've gotten
like all my gloves i've like patched up
all my stuff like i've gotten i'm warm
and i have enough food and i've like
boiled this soup so it's going to be
warm so when i go out in the cold it'll
be like i'll keep warming and i'll do
all this and then i just have to sleep
until because you can't go to night time
because it's just
you die of cold like it's just so bad
it's like minus 30 minus 40.
so i'm like wait until the morning and i
sleep and i time it all right and then i
sleep and then it's like day amount of
day like left question mark and i go
outside and it's a blizzard
and i just can't what can you do best
like plans of my cement i'm just like
[ __ ] so i went back indoors just waiting
for the blizzard to pass
and then i go asleep for two hours wait
for the blizzard to pass and then the
blizzard pass and it's like
four hours of daylight left and i'm like
well
i have to go now because i don't enough
stuff so it's something walk and then i
walk and then like
[ __ ] wolves man i find this gun it's
my last story about this i find this gun
and i think that there's like a clip or
whatever right and then it's like up in
the top corner and it says all right
this is how many shots aren't then it's
like wolf i'm trying to like avoid this
pack of wolves and one of them sees me
i'm walking towards me and i'm like [ __ ]
and i loaded up i'm like all the sights
on this are like slightly broken they're
slightly off like i cleaned the gun so
hopefully it should be okay and i'm like
all right i'll wait for them to get like
a little bit closer and i go
like
[ __ ] no bullets i thought there was
bullets in it oh no jumps on my face and
i'm like stabbing him in the face with a
knife like bleeding everywhere bandaged
up oh yeah i died like a day later
because or like two hours later because
i just like it succumbed like it just
once one thing happens it just like
piles on super great game really really
enjoying it you reminded me of one of
the things i did like about the revenant
which was how many times i felt myself
physically reacting right like cold yeah
like they go in the river and i'm like
and like things happen and you just like
feel like i felt a bunch of those
moments and i think that they did a good
job with that for sure
like
i was like cringing i'm sitting next to
some couple this is the great thing
about going to the movie theater solo is
like you go and get those front row
seats with like the bar you put your
feet up no problem because every couple
that sits up there is leaving a space
between them right you decide you're
like hey guys
i love it all right chris waters great
to have you on thanks very much for
watching peter brown thank you so much
for coming in sorry we said we'd take it
for 50 minutes and then kept you for now
you're keeping me from getting work done
i love it that's true uh thanks so much
to andy bauman has been holding a camera
on his waist
for like the past hour and 20 minutes
thank you so much to everyone who's been
watching the show over the past couple
of weeks it's great to be back live uh
we're still playing with the format
still like tightening it up figuring out
what we're going to talk about uh but
video games are coming out again so
we've got a bunch of stuff to talk about
over the next couple weeks we should be
back in the studio in three weeks time
hopefully first week of february we've
got a really tight turnaround for when
with the set gets built so we'll we're
aiming for that we'll hope we're also
going to get the podcast version up
around then as well we're working on it
but if you have any other suggestions
feel free to hit me up at danny dwyer on
twitter feel free to hit up anyone on
the production staff andy josh dan eric
tay uh and of course uh put it in the
comments we're in there talking on
gamespot on youtube
all over the shop thank you so much for
watching the lobby this look we'll be
back
this week we'll be back next week
tuesday 2 pm pacific same time same
place we'll see you then enjoy week of
video games
you